Welcome to Tokyo.
I'm here.
And?
And what, Mom?
You think he'll just be sitting here,
waiting for someone to bring him home?
Who are you?
What are you doing here?
- Who are you?
- What do you want?
What are you doing?
This is my father.
What do you want?
Can you tell us anything?
We have been waiting.
Let's just forget this happened.
Are you kidding me?
You flew halfway around the world
looking for something.
And all you found was Dad was apparently
a lying a**hole.
I want to show you something.
He just wasn’t who you say he was.
Got to give it to the guy.
He had two families and still had time
to be obsessed with work.
It was important.
Do you even know what he did?
Woah, hey!
What's in here?
I didn't know it was there.
They were there.
In San Francisco.
Like soldiers or something.
With this on their uniforms.
You think that your father was working for them?
This stuff was in his safe.
She wants to know if he was with you.
When it happened, was he with you?
What difference does that make now?
You don't think it would've
made a difference
if he'd been here with us instead?
No, he wasn’t with me.
About a week after that, we got a call
from the state police in Fairbanks, Alaska
saying the bush plane he was on
disappeared in a storm.
They never found the wreckage.
What are you all going to do now?
“You can do this.”
“I believe in you.”
That’s what you said that time.
But I didn’t want to disappoint you.
So I couldn’t face you...
How was I supposed to know
I’d never see you again?
Colonel Shaw?
We want to find out what
happened to my father.
Now you can choke down that
mountain of Monarch bullsh*t
about your father disappearing
without a trace.
Or, we can get the hell out of here
right now and find out
what really happened with your dad.
Did our dad really work for them?
For Monarch?
It is your family business.
It's not our family business…
it's the family curse.
Go! Run!
May!
May, come on!
I got you!
Come on, hurry!
Kentaro!
-Let’s go!
Kentaro?
-We’re going to go.
Go!
They said the signal was so weak, they almost didn’t
hear me on the emergency channel.
I never thought I’d thank someone for
abandoning their family but
here we are.
He'd scribble down
every crazy thing he came across
till his pencils were nothing but nubs.
- Dad did that.
- Yeah?
He'd sharpen them
with the penknife that he carried.
Left the shavings everywhere.
I know that handwriting.
Me too.
He survived.
Monarch may know how to find the Titans,
but they don't know how to find Dad.
Do we? I already searched his office an--
Not the one in San Francisco.
Dad would sing these cheesy commercials.
What is the secret of the triangle shape?
The secret of deliciousness is...
I'm not going to tell you!
Tada!
San Francisco.
Alaska.
Africa.
This must be the path he took.
Is that--
He's alive.
Dad! Over here, Dad!
-Dad!
-Up here!
Dad!
We gotta get out of here!
Come on, we gotta move! Now!
Now! Move! We need to go now!
Kentaro, we gotta go!